danke wir haben verstanden sagen die
Damen und Herren von der Ampelkoalition
in Berlin wirklich das Wahlergebnis wird
zwar lauthals bejammert aber bei der
Suche nach den Schuldigen wird man dann
doch eher in den anderen Parteien fündig
wegen schlechem Stil und falscher
Inhalte und so jetzt soll aber alles
wirklich besser werden schließlich leben
wir in Krisenzeiten zumindest das
nächste Verfallsdatum für politische
Glaubwürdigkeit steht schon im Kalender
9 juni 2024 der Tag der Wahl zum
Europäischen
Parlament nach der wahlklatsche was muss
die Ampel ändern jetzt in der
phönixrunde
phönixrunde herzlich Willkommen bei uns
meine Gäste Anna Klaus ist bei uns sie
leiten das Ressort Meinung und Debatte
beim Spiegel sind gleichzeitig
Korrespondentin des Magazins in Bayern
und sie haben ein Buch geschrieben mit
dem Titel Söder die andere
Biografie albercht von Lucke ist
Publizist und Redakteur der Blätter für
deutsche und internationale
Politik Meer ist Schweizer Publizist in
Deutschland und sie schreiben unter
anderem für das Magazin cizero und
Roland abold ist Geschäftsführer des
Meinungsforschungsinstituts Infratest
dimap bekannt auch dafür für die ARD den
sogenannten Deutschlandtrend zu
erstellen Herr von Lucke vorsichtig
ausgedrückt hat die Ampel einen
Denkzettel erhalten am Wochenende bei
den beiden Wahlen warum haben Sie denn
die ampelparteien in Bayern und Hessen
so schlecht abgest Schnitten ja das ist
die großfrage schlecht hin da könnte man
vieles aufführen es ist zu allererst
natürlich die Performance das miserable
Erscheinungsbild der Ampel mit dem sie
sich selbst auch Erfolge zuichte gemacht
hat das ist der Kern und ein zweites
kommt hinzu es hat die Ampel aber im
Zusammenspiel mit der Union am Ende das
Thema Migration dass man viel früher
hätte angehen müssen die Kommunen haben
Anfang des Jahres schon die weiße Fahne
gehisst haben sie am Ende des
Wahlkampfes so nach vorne gespielt dass
der Zufluss zuur AFD fast zwangsläufig
war also doppeltes Missgeschick Versagen
im Erscheinungsbild und das die ganze
Zeit und dann auch letztlich genau das
Thema was vor allem einem genützt hat
der AFD fr Klaus in beiden Ländern hat
die Union ja gewonnen sie werden der
Amtsinhaber wird das bleiben in der
gleichen Koalition wahrscheinlich sogar
in Bayern hat Markus höder allerdings
das schlechteste Ergebnis in der
Geschichte der CSU bei Landtagswahlen
eingefahren ist zwar ganz knapp unter
dem von
2018 ähm wird die CDU denn irgendwann
mal wieder zu alterstärke zurückführen
finden können ja Markus Söder jedenfalls
hat ein total
m cleveres kann man vielleicht sagen äh
clevere Erklärung gefunden wie er das
jetzt schöne redet nämlich ind dem er
sagt Bayern hat Stabilität gewählt ja
prima ergebtnis sozusagen genauso
schlecht wie das letzte Mal gewesen aber
ob er damit durchkommen wird ist die
Frage weil die Wahl hat ja wie sie sagen
gezeigt äh dass in Bayern jetzt offenbar
unionsergebnis üblich sind wie in
anderen Bundesländern ähnlich wie in
Hessen hier in schlesfg- Holstein der
Kollege Günther hatte über 40% da kann
sich die CSU jetzt natürlich schwer
hinstellen und sagen wir sind besser wir
sind größer wir sind Bayern wenn sie
quasi genau gleiches Ergebnis hat wie
die anderen jetzttig verstehe auch als
Problem Söder dann sehen ja das ist
natürlich der Ministerpräsident auf den
kommt's an das hat er überall plakatiert
also muss er nachher auch für dieses
Ergebnis ger stehen me ja die AFD hat ja
stark zulegen können in Bayern
drittstärkste Kraft in Hessen sogar ganz
klar zweitstärkste Kraft über
18% weshalb kann die Partei denn jetzt
auch im Westen derartig punkten weil
drei Parteien ein strukturelles Problem
haben es haben sich nicht die Ampel die
Ampel ist ungewöhnlich für Deutschland
weil es ist eine Dreier Regierung in der
Schweiz sind wir das gewohnt wir haben
eine vier Regierung vier Parteien und
das führt natürlich zu Diskussionen die
nach außen dringen und in Deutschland
sofort als Streit
und Gespaltenheit und als das
wahrgenommen wird das das SE aber das
nur dieche Erscheinungsform aber die
strukturelle Frage ist das größte
Problem haben die Sozialdemokraten nicht
nur in Deutschland aber hier ganz ganz
gravierend und tief auch die Grünen
haben ein Problem sind ein Problem aus
meiner Sicht und die ja 75 Jahre nach
dem nach nach der Freisinnigen
Revolution die misslungen ist haben wir
immer noch eine liberale Partei die
nicht vom Fleck kommt weil sie keinen
Respons hat in der Gesellschaft weil das
ist eigentlich eine ungewöhnliche Partei
für die deutsche Geschichte für uns ist
es eine Regierungspartei eine Partei die
die Demokratie gemacht hat und hier ist
seine randpartei das besorgt mich als
Schweizer
abold nach weiß man immer alles besser
äh neah zu alle Parteien glauben ja dass
Migration ein wichtiges
wahlentscheidendes Thema war sie wollen
sie jetzt auch angehen aber war das auch
so war das migrationsthema das ja am
Schluss stark diskutiert worden ist war
das wahlentscheidend es war auf jeden
Fall unter den wichtigsten
wahlentscheidenden Themen ich denke ähm
es wird jetzt viel auf das Thema
Migration auch geguckt und auch das als
das alleinige äh Thema postuliert ich
denke dass das eingebettet ist in eine
strukturelle große Verunsicherung in
weiten Teilen der Gesellschaft äh die
mit verschiedenen sage ich mal Sorgen
zusammenhängen da ist auch der
Klimawandel mit dabei da ist das Thema
Migration
Überfremdung Kriminalität und das alles
sozusagen
sind zum Teil natürlich auch
tatsächliche Probleme haben wir gerade
schon gehört in den Kommunen und so
weiter was auch feststellbar ist zum
anderen aber auch sage ich mal sorgen
für die Zukunft auch Richtung können wir
unseren Lebensstandard halten was
passiert
in der Gesellschaft insofern ist es ein
wichtiges Thema und auch eins was was
einiges bewegt hat aber es ist
eingebettet in größeren
Gesamtzusammenhang aus aus was unsere
Zahlen dazu hergeben das heißt also
Friedrich Merz hat recht dass
das schlechte Abschneiden der
ampelparteien eine Quittung für deren
Migrationspolitik ist ja das wäre viel
zu einfach ich würde sagen Friedrich
März hat maßgeblich dazu beigetragen
dass das migrationsthema am Ende nicht
gelöst wurde wenn man sich bewusst macht
in welcher populistischen Tonlage die
übrigens nur deshalb nicht mehr
Widerspruch in den eigenen Reihen
gefunden hat ausgenommen Daniel Günther
der so mutig war zu sagen das ist nicht
meine Tonlage wenn Friedrich Merz sagte
Migranten nehmen deutschen die
zahnarztplätze weg weil sie sich ihre
Gebisse machen lassen eine unsächliche
Aussage vor dem Hintergrund dass man
weiß dass die Menschen die hierherkmen
18 Monate lang erstmal nur die
Notbehandlung bekommen reiner AFD sprech
dann hat er damit quasi genau die
Intonation getätigt die eigentlich der
AFD entspricht und er hat das muss man
sich sehr bewusst machen ein Wahlsieger
Boris rein gestern gekürt der eine ganz
andere Tonlage anstimmt der eigentliche
Wahlsieger ist nicht Friedrich März der
Wahlsieger Boris rin ist ein Mann der
mit sehr viel moderateren Tönen zu Felde
zieht der genau der Linie Günther Daniel
Günther und aber natürlich Hendrik wüst
entspricht und die eigentliche große
Debatte in der Union wird jetzt
aufbrechen nämlich die Frage die da
lautet gehen wir doch wieder stärker ein
Kurs in Richtung Mitte mit dem Wissen
darum dass wir wahrscheinlich eines
Tages auch mit den Grünen koalieren
müssen oder betreiben wir weiter eine
Polarisierung vom Schlage märz das halte
ich aber für verherend denn das eine
muss man ja sehen 18% für die AFD in
Hessen bei
30% rechts der CSU in Bayern wir haben
also eine Schlagseite auf der rechten
Seite und die ist maßgeblich auch durch
die Intonation von Friedrich März
betrieben worden das hat der AFD in die
K wir müssen ja wollen ja über die Ampel
vor allen Dingen reden aber Herr Meer
hat
z rhetorisch gezündelt für mich ist das
auf zu kleinem Feuer die Analyse muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen das
migrationsthema ist ein europäisches
Thema ist ein ganz zentrales Thema was
sich da alles noch subsummiert wenn sie
natürlich sagen Angst vor Kriminalität
das subsummiert sich unter dem
migrationsthema es ist ein ganz
gewaltiges europäisches Thema weil es
ein nurthema der Menschen ist wenn
Fremde kommen das geht in unsere
Vorzeiten zurück dass die Menschen
reagieren emotional es ist das
emotionale Thema dass die anderen
mitnimmt in diese Emotion ich komme aus
einem Land ich will dann nachher nicht
mehr die Schweiz als Beispiel bringen ab
bei uns ist die AFD namens SVP die
größte Partei und diese Partei wird
großteils von Arbeitnehmern gewählt drum
habe ich gesagt die Sozialdemokraten
riesen Problem welche sanitärinallateur
sieht sich noch in der Sozialdemokratie
repräsentiert das frage ich mich nicht
jeder Politologe selbstverständlich sein
Sie bitte nicht beleidigt wenn ich ein
bisschen so
unakademischung geht mir darum es geht
mir darum dass die diese Migration dass
da der der
März populistisch was auch immer das
heißt dass er da sehr polemisch sich
ausgedrückt hat wir wissen ja alle was
er eigentlich gemeint hat das wissen wir
alle aber es natür klar die AFD ist für
mich damit alles klar ist her l eine
unsägliche eine völlig unerträgliche
Partei ich bekämpfe seit 30 Jahren
können Sie nachfragen Herrn blochen
diese SVP aber ich sehe auch was die
repräsentiert für die Leute dass sie
dort dass sie für die Stimmen das ist
ein ganz fundamentales Problem ein
europäisch nur kurz auflöen SVB
Schweizer Volkspartei Blocher ist der
Vorsitzende also
Einw
der AFD wahrscheinlich sehe die Schweiz
oder auch Deutschland anders aus wenn es
nicht seithundert und Jahrtausend
Migration gegeben hätte Herr abold jetzt
wird ja die Verschärfung der
Migrationspolitik von vielen Seiten
gefordert auch aus der ampelausfung von
der FDP aber auch aus der SPD da muss
jetzt was passieren ist das auch etwas
was letztendlich die Menschen da
erwarten wie wie soll diese Verschärfung
Aussehen gibt es da irgendwelche
demografischen
demoskopischen Daten wenn wir jetzt
konkret auf die auf die Landtagswahlen
am am Wochenende schauen da haben wir
gezielt gefragt die Wähler ob eine
andere eine Wende in der asyl- und
Migrationspolitik gewünscht ist mit dem
Ziel dass weniger Zuwanderer zu uns
kommen und des es in Bayern mit 80%
befürwortet in in Hessen mit 70% also
das kann man mit klarem Ja beantworten
die Wähler erwarten dass sich hier was
ändert bis in die in die Grünen Anhänger
rein äh hat es eine leichte Mehrheit
also das ist völlig außer Frage dass die
Bürger dort das erwarten wir haben
letztlich auch mal in dem in dem
Deutschlandtrend abgefragt was für
Maßnahmen dort befürwortet werden oder
oder was dort gesehen wird das sind
natürlich die Themen auch Definition
Obergrenze da gibt's eine leichte
Mehrheit zumindest dafür auch auch
andere Maßnahmen jetzt dass man auch auf
europäische Ebene das ganze Thema
natürlich angeht und dort versucht das
zu lösen also es sind im Grunde schon
viele der Dinge die auch auch in der
Politik diskutiert werden als mögliche
Lösungen wo immer so Richtung 60% sagen
ja das sollte man vielleicht probieren
also der Wähler die Wähler und
Wählerinnen und Wähler erwarten dort
definitiv eine Antwort der Politik da
gibt's gar keine Frage Frau Klaus der
Chef der Partei die da am stärksten
vermöbelt worden ist am Wochenende
Christian Lindner von der FDP der hat ja
am Abend von einem also das Wahlergebnis
gemeint von einem Auftrag
gesprochen die Regierungsarbeit kritisch
zu prüfen das hatte man etwas patziger
ausdrücken können ähm sie B sie beteuert
ja immer wieder die Ampel sie hätten
verstanden das habe ich am Anfang auch
gesagt nach jedem Koalitionskrach nach
jedem Koalitionskompromiss nach
tagelangen Koalitionsverhandlungen auch
nach misslungenen Wahlen gab's auch
schon vorher
m warum tut sie sich damit so schwer
wahrscheinlich weil sie zu dritt sind ja
wobei man ja sagen muss dass die
Vorgängerregierung ja streng Genom auch
zuritt war oder wenn man jetzt die Union
als Partner aus CDU und CSU zusammen die
csuf bestehen genau und wir hatten ja
damals auch fast ein Bruch als es ums
Thema Obergrenze ging von der sie vorhin
Sprachen also
gut aber es sind jetzt natürlich schon
drei wirklich sehr unterschiedliche
Parteien die alle sehr unterschiedliche
Köpfe sehr unterschiedliche Charaktere
auch sehr unterschiedliche Ausrichtungen
haben und man vergisst ja manchmal dass
es quasi noch so eine Art Opposition
gibt weil sich ja wahlweise die FDP oder
die grün
als Opposition innerhalb der Regierung
generieren und es einfach nicht schaffen
geräuschlos Ihre Probleme zu lösen weil
dass man Probleme hat und um Lösungen
ringt ist ja klar aber warum warum muss
man das in so einer Lautstärke und mit
mit so einem Gezeter immer tun weil die
FDP und das forsert seit einem Jahr
versucht sich alleine über die
Eigenmarke zu profilieren und das hat
sie jetzt noch einmal sehr deutlich
gemacht das was Christian Lindner sagt
und wir müssen uns bewusst machen sie
fingen so schön an mit der Einleitung
Herr Kehler wir haben verstanden die
Ampel sagt wir haben verstanden es
versteht halt nie dass wir es versteht
jeweils dass ich der jeweils eigenen
Partei etwas höchst unterschiedliches
und das was die FDP zum Besten gibt und
sagt was sie verstanden hat diesmal
wiederholt und Christian nner hat es
sehr deutlich gesagt war die Tatsache
aus seiner Sicht dass die Themen die
eigentlich Themen der FDP sind
interessanterweise übrigens auch
Migration ich frage mich allerdings wie
er das meint das kann eigentlich
klassischerweise aus FDP sich nicht nur
primär Begrenzung sein sondern auch die
Notwendigkeit von vernünftiger Migration
das mag er gemeint haben er meint ent
Bürokratisierung er meint sichere
Wirtschaft er sagt all das kommt nicht
vor und diarei der Generalsekretär ging
noch mal einen Schritt weiter der sagte
noch am Wahlabend nachdem er übrigens
derjenige war das will man mal deutlich
gesagt haben der der eigen dem eigenen
Koalitionspartner im Vorfeld der Wahl im
Thema Migration gewissermaßen Friedrich
März noch übersteigend und ich sag ihn
Herr Meer ich bin doch nicht gegen eine
Lösung des migrationsthemas das
migrationsthema ist ein jahrhundertthema
das Land will aber nicht Polemik und
Populismus vom Schlag März es will
Lösung und wenn ein Mann wie jerei noch
davor den Grünen vorwirft sie seien ein
Sicherheitsrisiko des Landes dann ist
das ein Ton in der Koalition der
eigentlich schon auf Trennung läuft und
J sagt jetzt das ist ja ein bisschen
auch eine Anderung fast von Auflösung
auch bei Lindner wir werden jetzt genau
überprüfen ob wir in dieser Koalition
noch überhaupt etwas durchsetzen können
und wenn ja was und ob es sich sinngemä
überhaupt noch lohnt damit ist zum
ersten Mal so etwas im Raum wie eine
Ansage es ist möglicherweise auch
notwendig dieses Ding vorzeitig platzen
zu lassen weil wir nicht weiterken das
ist schon ein starkes Stück die ersten
harisse im ampelgebäude möglicherweise
Herr Meer wenn ich Sie richtig
verstanden habe Bedauern sie ja etwas
dass die Liberalen in Deutschland nicht
ganz so
präsent sind auch nicht so politisch
erfolgreich sind wie in der in der
Schweiz woran liegt aber dass das jetzt
in Bayern aus dem Landtag geflogen sind
zum wiederholten Male in nur haarscharf
an einer Katastrophe vorbeigeschrammt
sind was haben denn diese Misserfolge
bei den Landtagswahlen und es gibt ja
noch mehrere Bundesländer aus den
letzten Monaten wo die FDP rausgeflogen
ist mit der Performance der Partei auf
Bundesebene zu tun ja zunächst einm habe
ich einfach gesagt es gibt wenig
Sensibilität für das freisinnige
Gedanken gut ich benutze jetzt bewusst
einen Schweizer Begriff der allerdings
aus Deutschland kam das freisinnig viel
der schönere Begriff als dieses lapprige
liberal was heißt do freistad Bayern
nein ich ja aber ich ZTE vom Freisinn
und diese
freisinnige diese freisininnige diese
freisinnige revolutionäre Kultur das ist
es
Paulskirche die gibt's hier weniger und
darauf können die weniger passieren sie
waren ja nie wirklich stark und jetzt
kommt hinzu dass um stark zu sein sich
diese Partei sehr stark aus sich heraus
profilieren müsste sie haben es
angesprochen viel stärker als die
anderen im Grunde genommen viel stärker
und das tun sie nicht sie sind im Grunde
genommen die bürgerlichste Partei dort
drin in ihrem auftreten wenn Sie die
Figuren sehen das ist sehr ein ein eine
bürgerliche
Selbstinszenierung mir passt das das ist
in Ordnung aber das wirkt nicht richtig
es ist ja auch so das ist ganz wichtig
sie sagen es ist es he ein
jahrhunderttha aber sie möchten in
Deutschland wenn ich sie höre das 100
Thema leise behandeln also in ein
atmosphä F wie man Französisch sagt also
so in einer guten Atmosphäre unter uns
möchten wir das Problem ausmachen nein
die Polemik von her Merz gehört dazu zu
Demokratie der Krach der Streit das
aufeinander brallen auch das hatten sie
ja mal in guten Zeiten denken Sie an den
herbert Wehner der kann man ja hochleben
lassen wie der auf die Gegner losging da
funktioniert etwas und das fehlt vielen
Menschen darf ich das noch darf ich das
nur ich bin g zu weit es fehlt dieses
zugriffige dieses aufeinander ein
bisschen
losdonnen das möchten die Leute das
übrigens sind die Bürger die Chefs
dieser Leute und diese Leute benehmen
sich wie die Chefs der Bürger das ist
meine Erfahrung in Deutschland und das
passt mir gar nicht aber wenn ich
Antworten darf was die Leute glaube ich
auch nicht mögen ist dass man ih
irgendwelche schnellschusslösungen in
Aussicht
ne ich sag nur dass man quasi Lösung
sugeriert die nachher nicht kommt weil
ich nehme jedenfalls auch so eine Art
Vertrauenskrise war ja also auch
deswegen steigt ja vielleicht die
Popularität der AFD weil Bürgerinnen und
Bürger vielleicht nicht mehr wissen wem
kann man eigentlich Vertrauen klar das
kann man mit quasi einem
vertrauenswürdigen Kopf einem Politiker
einer Politikerin Lösen der man bei der
man sich irgendwie gut aufgehoben fühlt
aber was halt nichts bringt ist wenn man
irgendwie Lösungen wie so eine Integra
Obergrenze oder eine Obergrenze in
Aussicht stellt von der man dann schon
weiß es wird eh nicht passieren D das
das wird das Problem nicht lösen da
kommt man sich doch dann als Bürgerin
irgendwann auch verarscht vor und und
das widerspiegelt dann dieses
Wahlergebnis auch lass uns ganz kurz auf
die FDP gucken sie sagen jetzt glaube
ich bürgerliche Selbstinszenierung der
FDP Beil man hat ja das Gefühl wenn man
Christian Lindner so beobachtet der will
cooler sein als Udo Lindenberg oder
Johnny de also inszeniert sich in der
Öffentlichkeit auch in der Partei also
und zwar relativ clever und
professionell scheint der Partei aber
nicht wirklich zu nutzen ich denke sie
hatten gesagt in der Schweiz sind die
Liberalen oder die die Freisinnigen
Regierungspartei die FDP hat die längste
Zeit in der Bundesrepublik auch
mitregiert insofern so schwarz und weiß
würde ich das jetzt nicht sehen in jedem
Fall ist im Moment gerade eine
Gemengelage wo die FDP sich natürlich
unglaublich schwer tut wenn wir uns
zurückerinnern als wir aus der
coronapandemie kamen da war sozusagen s
die Macht der Freiheit ja da da war war
war dieses war diese Ideen besser
gelitten im Moment in diesen multiplen
Krisen auch von dieser Verunsicherung wo
wir vorher schon gesprochen haben jetzt
darf man nicht vergessen bei den Wahlen
zwei Tage vorher Ausbruch Nahostkrieg
das alles ist eigentlich eine
Gemengelage wo erstmal zumindest in
Deutschland das Thema Freiheit und so
weiter schweren Stand hat da geht's dann
eher Richtung wir müssen für die innere
Sicherheit sorgen für die äußere
Sicherheit diese ganzen them das spielt
natürlich eher Richtung
konservative rechte Parteien als jetzt
unbedingt zur zur zur zur FDP oder oder
auch zu den anderen ampelparteien
dementsprechend ja es ist im Moment eine
schwierige Gemengelage weil eben die FDP
sich schwer tut in diesen in diesen
verschiedenen Strömungen sich sich
ordentlich zu positionieren und die
Wähler auch sagen es ist uns nicht ganz
klar wofür die Partei jetzt eigentlich
steht und und natürlich auch bei den bei
den Wählern die die FDP gewählt haben
eine gewisse Enttäuschung besteht wie
bei den meisten ampelparteien dass nicht
das rausgekommen ist was man sich
eigentlich von der Koalition erwartet
hätte inwiefern sich das jetzt weiter
entwickelt das hängt wirklich von der ja
von der gesamtgemengelage ab das kann
sich wieder ändern und dann sprechen wir
wieder über andere Befunde lassen uns
vielleicht mal weil wir drei Parteien zu
bearbeiten haben auf der Ampel ganz nach
oben auf den Ampel bei den Ampelfarben
ganz nach oben gehen die
Sozialdemokraten haben ja in beiden
Ländern das schlechteste Weah Ergebnis
seit Bestehen der Bundesrepublik
eingefahren jetzt lassen wir viicht die
bayerische Sozialdemokratie Weg denn die
hatte ja schon seit vielen Jahren
Bodenberührung in der
Wählergunst aber gerade im Bezug auf
Hessen und auch auf die
Spitzenkandidatin wie ist dieses depakel
zustande gekommen ja maßgeblich durch
den Bund begründet ganz ganz stark das
ist schon das Dilemma natürlich einer
Person die auch an der Bundespolitik
beteiligt ist nennt sie faer das darf
man übrigens aber auch nie vergessen die
sich nicht nur nach der
Spitzenkandidatur gedrängt hat sie wurde
quasi ihr zu fußen Füßen gelegt weil sie
die stärkste Figur der SPD in Hessen war
über Jahre fast Jahrzehnte äh dann ist
sie quasi mit dieser ampelregierung nach
unten gerauscht und natürlich jetzt
letztlich auf dem unkämpftesten Feld der
Migrationspolitik als ihrem originären
Feld als Innenministerin besonders
geschädigt das ist das Dilemma der SPD
die aber ein grundsätzliches Dilemma
noch ich bin aber los trotzdem ich komme
gar nicht drüber hinweg ich muss noch
einmal wenigstens das ist so Schaden wir
haben viel zu viel auf dem Zettel aber
ich komme über den
freisinnigkeitsbegriff das muss ich dann
doch noch einmal wenigstens gesagt haben
nicht we parent ich Ende auch wieder bei
der SPD es ist schon rührend muss ich
Ihnen sagen Herr Meer der
freisinnigkeitsbegriff ist ein Begriff
den man nicht mehr nur auf die FDP
wahrscheinlich nie se deutlich gesagt
hat kaprizieren können wir haben eine
weit größere Verständigung darüber was
Freiheit und freisinnigkeit heute
bedeutet und deshalb ist das
Grundproblem natürlich dass in dem
enggeführten
freisinnigkeitsbegriff eines
wirtschaftsliberalen Freisinns kein
Tempolimit auf deutschen Autobahn jetzt
das was natürlich Lindner zurecht nach
vorne bringt ein Funktion der Wirtschaft
das immer ein Reduktionismus war es
kämpfen also hier alle Parteien das will
ich deutlich sagen die Grünen zu dem ja
sicherlich auch kommt um einen
Freiheitsbegriff um die Frage was ist
Freiheit und was ist das was übrigens
auch unter dem Blick von 1848 weil sie
das ins Felde führten bei Leibe nicht
mit einem schmalpurigen
vulgärliberalismus aus Teilen der FDP
noch irgendwas zu tun hat deswegen will
ich damit sagen dieser Freiheitsbegriff
ist deswegen so wichtig weil natürlich
auch die Sozialdemokratie und das ist
ein Teil des Problems früher den
Anspruch hatte auch inhaltlich in dieser
Koalition zu punkten sie hat ein
riesiges Problem und das ist das über
fazer hinausgehendes Problem sie ist in
gewisser Weise zu einem
kanzlerwahlverein ODF Scholz geschrumpft
Scholz der von Anfang an der Kanzler der
von Anfang an sagte mein Hauptziel ist
es in vier Jahren wiedergewählt zu
werden der aber unter der Strecke gar
nicht mehr klar gemacht hat weder was
soll diese Koalition keine Orientierung
stiftet keine Führung aber auch nicht
mehr klar machen kann wofür diese SPD
steht die SPD ist wahrscheinlich die am
wenigsten profilierte Kraft auch
aufgrund der Schwäche vieler ihrer
Minister und Ministerinnen während die
Grünen und die FDP wenigstens indem sich
Streit die K einwisses Profil haben das
ist das grundproem dieser SPD eine ein
strategischer Fehler nennen sie Feser da
überhaupt aufzustellen für diese als
Spitzenkandidatin also es war vor allem
doch ein strategischer Fehler von ihr zu
sagen ja ich kandidiere jetzt mal aber
wenn es nichts wird komme ich wieder
zurück nach Berlin wenn es allen recht
ist anders Moment noch ihr
Amt ja da schützt sie muss man
wahrscheinlich sagen die Tatsache dass
sie ansonsten die dritte frauus wie nett
wä äh die den Hut nehmen müsste und das
ist dann doch
eine recht schlechte Bilanz für einen
Kanzler der im Wahlkampf gesagt hat er
sei feminist und ich ich glaube das ist
wirklich ein ganz verheerendes Bild also
auch für mich als Journalistin ich achte
auf sowas und ich glaube der Scholz weiß
dass wir auf so etwas achten und
deswegen ähm hält er auch an ihr fest
aber es war wirklich schon ihr Fehler da
ähm so rumzulavieren und sagen ich
mach's nur wenn ich gewinne also wenn
man so in der Wahl reingeht be rötgen
dann braucht man sich einfach nicht
wundern wenn es am Ende nichts wird darf
ich darf ich bitte also ich will auch
nicht bei dem bleiben aber eine kleine
Antwort es geht nicht darum um den
Freiheitsbegriff es geht darum dass in
der Schweiz der freiind die machtpartei
ist die machtpartei bis heute die
machtpartei die die Dinge nachhaltig
seit 100 ja 175 Jahren bestimmt mit also
ganz stark sogar ein Peter Piel
vielleicht Sozialdemokrat sagt wir sind
alle
freisinnig wir sind ja das ist die
orientierungspartei das ist sie hier
nicht das wollte ich sagen aber die
Sozialdemokratie das ist nicht die nen
fer das ist viel tiefer sie haben
angesprochen das ist ganz tief das ist
eine
Identitätsproblematik diese
Partei man redet ja auch gern von
Arbeiter beewegung und meint die
Gewerkschaften damit das war eine
kulturelle Bewegung
B vor kurzem das ist gar nicht so lange
her die hat in wie einen Inhalt gegeben
einen gesellschaftlichen üb reine wählen
hinaus welche Person ist jetzt wo man
fühlte sich dort zu Hause und ich habe
es angesprochen ich ich weiß nicht
welche
Friseuse sich angesprochen führt von der
Sozialdemokratie die heute zusammen mit
den Grünen eigentlich eine Schicht
vertritt die völlig durch subventioniert
ist von den Universitäten über die NGOs
sind ja heute Gios und nicht NGOs über
alle diese Verwaltungsstellen 173 gender
Lehrstühle das musste man schaffen damit
man diese Leute versorgen kann und das
ist
eine natürlich absolut absolut es gibt
13 Forschung 13 lehrstüle glaube ich für
für Atom Atomforschung ich bitte Sie da
ist eine
durchsubventionierte Schicht die von der
Sozialdemokratie und von den Grünen von
denen natürlich das auch in Ordnung die
braucht es auch aber von den
Sozialdemokratie repräsentiert die sie
repräsentiert keine normalen
Arbeitnehmer mehr und die wählen die
machen die Verrücktheit das ist eine es
ist unerträglich und machen ihr Zeichen
bei dieser AFD ne ach da wollte ich
jetzt sagen 38% glaube ich der Arbeiter
haben die AFD gewählt also jene die
also wenig Bildung oder geringere
Bildung haben und wenig verdienen
38% haben die AFD gewählt das ist schon
das war wesentlich mehr als sonst ist
das auch eine Entwicklung dass die die
Arbeitnehmer gerade von der SPD sagen
fühlen sich nicht mehr vertreten es sind
insbesondere jetzt Arbeiter auch
niedrige Einkommensschichten auch die
in gewisser Weise auch wirtschaftliche
Ängste haben das geht immer auch um um
um Abstieg Halten des Lebensstandards
und so weiter wo wir wirklich gesehen
haben dass
dass dort die die AFD extrem punkten
kann was so ein bisschen
ähm bemerkenswert ist ist dass wir e
jetzt sehen dass sich das jetzt ändert
in den letzten Wahlen von der reinen
Protestbewegung dass sich das auch
verfestigt ne wir sehen jetzt auch
Wähler die wie zum wiederholten Mal AFD
wählen die jetzt auch in Bayern haben
fast 50% gesagt sie wählen die AFD aus
aus Überzeugung und nicht mehr nur aus
reinem Frust über über die anderen
Parteien auch auch in Hessen waren das
über 40% und da sieht man dass es
sozusagen dass da auch
Wanderungsbewegungen sind die AFD hat in
den beiden Landtagswahlkämpfen jetzt
eigentlich von allen Richtungen
Wähler abgezogen aber insbesondere z.B
in Hessen von
von von der SPD auch sehr viele von der
FDP auch sehr viele Grünen
zum und und auch von den von den
Nichtwählern weil wir vorher gesagt weil
sie vorher gesagt haben die bleiben zu
Hause in Bayern sind die nicht zu Hause
geblieben sondern wir haben fast 75%
Wahlbeteiligung eigentlich das was wir
uns vor einigen Jahren immer gewünscht
haben dass die Leute wieder
partizipieren dass sie nicht diesen exit
wählen und sozusagen in in die Wahl
Verweigerung gehen sondern dass sie
davon haben aber in den letzten Jahren
auch schon häufiger AFD Politikerinnen
und Politiker profitiert dass sie nicht
Wähler aktivieren K vielleicht jetzt
kein neues Phänomen nicht in dieser
Größenordnung das heißt die AFD tritt
gerade eine riesige politische Erbschaft
in Deutschland an das das kann man so
sehen also auf jeden Fall die die sich
sich davor fürchten abgehängt zu werden
die die irgendwie sagen wir müssen alles
tun damit im Grunde genommen das so
bleibt dass wir unseren Lebensstandard
halten können und so weiter und das sind
natürlich Arbeiter das sind Leute in in
kleineren Städten nicht in den in den
Großstädten überwiegend und so weiter
und so fort und die dort wird die AFD zu
zu dem Ansprechpartner für diese
Wählerinnen und Wähler und jetzt
sprechen wir über Bayern und das sind
wirtschaftlich sagen wir mal
einigermaßen starke südliche Länder wenn
wir jetzt auf die nächsten aufs nächste
Jahr blicken sie haben die Europawahl
angesprochen dann kommen die die Wahlen
in Ostdeutschland da haben wir im Moment
in unseren ländertrends 30% Plus und
wenn sich das sozusagen weiter steigert
kann das sozusagen natürlich auch noch
höher gehen also da wir müssen ja in der
phönixrunde ungefähr so alle zwei bis di
Wochen die Frage stellen wo ist
eigentlich Olaf
Scholz es gibt ja kaum eine Wahl die in
der letzten Zeit wo die Bundespolitik so
starken Einfluss genommen hat welche
Verantwortung trägt er eigentlich für
diese für dieses desaströse Wahlergebnis
seiner eigenen Partei aber eben auch der
beiden anderen ampelparteien ich meine
aus demoskopischer Sicht äh die Wähler
sind unzufrieden nur 27% äh haben jetzt
auch in bei den Landtagswahlen gesagt
sie sind zufrieden 27% haben gesagt der
ist ein guter Kanzler und das was hier
immer diskutiert wird ist auch in der
Öffentlichkeit oder bei den Wählerinnen
und Wählern so über 80% wünschen sich
einfach dass er den Kurs der Regierung
klarer vorgibt dass er diese diese
Konflikte auch stärker moderiert und in
dem Sinne würde ich sagen dass diese
Zurückhaltung auch so ein gewisses
Vakuum dort schafft wo dann diese
Unsicherheit und im Ende ist es einfach
eine Wahl vor massiver Unsicherheit vor
unglaublich vielen Sorgen Konflikten und
so weiter die sie immer weiter aufbauen
wie gesagt nah Ost gibt dann noch das
züpfelchen oben drauf und in dem
dementsprechend ist dann eine
Erwartungshaltung an mehr Führung ja
aber andererseits hat doch Angela Merkel
irgendwie auch nicht arg viel anders
gemacht wie damals Olaf Scholz
jedenfalls diese diese Frage wo ist
Angela Merkel oder wann erklärt sie sich
endlich oder kann sie sich nicht malhr
so ausdrücken dass sie sie auch
verstehen und nicht gleich alle
einschlafen und so das war ja eigentlich
vergleichbar mit dem Problem dass Olaf
Scholz auch hat trotzdem war sie total
beliebt also jedenfalls gegen Ende ihrer
oder so sagen in der Mitte gegen Ende
jetzt auch nicht GL asymmetrische
Demobilisierung ich meine es Streit ja
auch so eine gewissever a wenn man nicht
irgendwie wie ein Markus Söder wirklich
an jedem Tag fünf Bierzelte oder drei
waren es glaube ich besucht und Dach die
Gegend rennt wie wie ein Getriebener
also Souveränität der Scholz ja
vielleicht schon eruck hat man leider
gar nicht den eruck hat leider in
keinster Weise die Bevölkerung hat nicht
war er nicht und Merkel das gleiche
Verhalten aber doch weil wir in einer
völlig anderen Zeit sind in einer völlig
anderen Zeit und Olaf Scholz hat für
mein Verständnis den absoluten
Kardinalfehler gemacht zu glauben er
könne
mit dem Modus merkelensis wenn ich das
mal so sagen darf mit dem merkelmus
weiter regieren zu glauben im
Schlafwagen gewissermaßen dem Land
suggerieren bis also zur
Unglaubwürdigkeit sondergleichen wir
sind auf einem guten Weg wir gehen ein
grünes Wirtschaftswunder bleiben wir
gelassen bleiben wir cool das hat im
Sommer dieses Jahres und wä mal
interessant ob die Demoskopie das auch
wiedergibt den Höhepunkt erreicht als
Scholz versprach wir gehen jetzt in
völlig anderer Facon aus dieser
Sommerpause wir fangen völlig neu an
und kaum war die Sommerpause beendet
kloppten sich Lisa Paus und Lindner wie
die Kesselflicker also Finanzminister
und Familienministerin es war ein
Disaster und wenn eine solche klupf
zwischen Anspruch und Realität entsteht
und der Kanzler keinerlei Anstalten
macht dass irgendwie zu kitten diesen
Graben zu überbrücken und
interessanterweise abgesehen fragen wir
uns doch mal selbst abgesehen von seiner
großen zeitenwänder ich sag schon groß
weil die in Erinnerung also noch immer
viel größer wird weil danach nichts kam
nie wieder eine Ansage kam in der der
Kanz da abgesehen von zwei fatalen
machtworten die man eigentlich auch nur
mindestens höchstens einmal in einer
Legislatur sprechen darf er letztlich
nie klar gemacht hat wo die Reise
hingeht und eigentlich letztlich drei
Leichen mittlerweile auf dem
Schlachtfeld liegen nämlich eine völlig
erledigte Grüne Partei mit mit ihren
ökologischen Projekten voll an die Wand
sprich auch gegen die FDP gerannt ist
eine FDP die Opposition permanent gegen
die Regierung in dem fallal gegen die
Grünen gespielt hat ein Kanzler der die
ganze Zeit schweigend darüber stand und
eigentlich nie interveniert hat führt zu
einem richtig und ich nehme das als
wirkliches demokratieproblem langsam war
ein Staats ein ein Verlust an
staatsvertrauen ein Verlust an
Handlungsfähigkeit dieses Staates und
das
badet diese Regierung aus und sehe ich
sehe beim besten Willen auch nicht wie
der Kanzler wieder Luft unter die Segel
bekommen soll ich glaube mittlerweile
wird es im Land nur noch mit geilenhumor
genommen und die Leute erwarten von
dieser Regierung fast nichts mehr wenn
sie nicht jetzt geleitet und wer sollte
es anders sein nur durch einen
führungsstarken Kanzler endlich einen
anderen Modus findet der nicht mehr
Streit bedeutet ja aber dann sie haben
angesprochen war erstens eine ganz
andere Zeit und Angela Merkel hat im
Grunde genommen die Politik bis zur
nicht mehr Erfahrbarkeit runtergedimmt
ich sage immer hat gewirkt für die
Politik wie in einem in einem Zimmer wo
man das Licht sukzessive herunternimmt
am Schluss sieht man nichts mehr sie hat
die unpolitik zur Politik gemacht und
dann kommt dann kommt Scholz und will da
weiterfahren an hen in einer Zeit in der
nur die größten Probleme sind inklusive
das größte überhaupt Krieg das größte
überhaupt also das ist einfach ganz
gewaltig und in einer Zeit in der sie
haben die Grünen angesprochen wir haben
über die noch wenig gesagt in der eine
ja in der eine Partei in der Regierung
den Vizekanzler stellt die ich als das
Wort ist bekannt in Deutschland als über
griffig bezeichnen würde die den Leuten
im Kühlschrank kckt Ihnen die kleine
große Freiheit des Autos mies macht ob
das jetzt richtig ist oder nicht mir
geht's nicht um das es geht drum wie
wird das wahrgenommen wie wird das
wahrgenommen die W die schreiben da in
den in den grünen obrigkeitsgebieten 20
Stunden Kilometer das nehmen die Leute
wahr über das müssen wir reden
das die Leute wollen doch eigentlich in
Ruhe g en werden von der Politik also
natürlich Migration ist ein wichtiges
Thema viele haben Angst von vor V
wirtschaftlichen absieg aber ich habe
denru nicht man vorschreibt wie ich
heize
schlussollen R
gelassenation hat die FP
Recht die Leute die Leute werden selber
auf riesige Fehler gemacht das will
keiner leugnen es war ein riesiges
Problem D dass eine Politik aus dem
Hause greichen gemacht wurde ich rede
gar nicht über die familiären
Verstrickung die natürlich fatal gewirkt
haben die aber letztlich eine
technokratische Herangehensweise
bedeutet die dann übrigens Robert
habbeck selber das muss man ihmer wieder
zugute halten der so selbstkritisch wie
kaum ein anderer angeht und sagte asche
auf mein Haupt da haben wir die soziale
Lage völlig fehle eingeschätzt nur wenn
Politiker und sie tragen ja heute das
blaugelbe
solidaritäts Label am Hals also ihr
wunderbaren
ihr ihr ihren wunderbaren Schlips der ja
nun genau die Farben der Liberalen
verkörpert der Freisinnigen W der
freisin der FDP natürlich darin bestehte
bestand übrigens ganz mit kritisiert von
einem wirklichen Freisinnigen wie
Gerhard Baum der gesagt hat wenn die
Politik der FDP die Grünen frontal
vorzuführen sie regelrecht an die Wand
zu stellen und nicht intern Kritik zu
üben sondern von vorne rein qua
Selbstprofilierung die eigen den eigenen
Koalitionspartner zum Gegner sich ausz
auszuwählen WOB Baum sagte das wäre
unter Helmut Schmidt nie vorgekommen
Helmut Schmidt hätte für Kleid gesorgt
hätte gesagt das findet in meiner
Koalition nicht statt wenn so etwas
stattfindet dann erledigst du den
Koalitionspartner und die Ironie besteht
darin und das ist der eigentliche Witz
wo die Liberalen sich fragen müssen man
wird dadurch auch nicht stärker die
vermeintlich so freisinigen sind ja
nicht stärker geworden sie sind auch
schwach geblieben das heißt wenn sich
drei so streiten und ein Kanzler nicht
drüber steht dann macht man den Auftrag
den man ja am Anfang hatte wir wollen
eine Transformation bewerkstelligen man
macht ih unmöglich da da gebe ich Ihnen
Recht aber da hätte eine andere
Verhaltensweise in der Koalition eine
interne Klärung nicht so viel verbrannte
Erde hinterlassen das ist doch ich hatte
ja gesagt wir kommen noch zu den
Bündnisgrünen Frau Klaus da gibt's ja
auch die Frage wer zerlegt jetzt was in
nächster Zeit innerhalb der Ampel wenn
der Bundeskanzler möglicherweise mit
seinen Ausgleichsmaßnahmen nicht so
durchkommt der Chef der Grünen der kchef
Omid nuripur hat ja auch noch am
Wahlabend glaube ich gesagt er sieht
überhaupt keine Veranlassung für eine
inhaltliche Kurskorrektur der Stil muss
ich ändern der Umgangsstil in der Ampel
hat die Ampel wirklich in erster Linie
ein Kommunikationsproblem geht's gar
nicht so sehr um die
Inhalte es geht natürlich schon immer
auch um die Inhalte und wie man sie
quasi rüber bringt wie sieade ja auch
gerade gesagt habe ob es so wirkt wie da
möchte jetzt gleich jemand in den
Heizungskeller steigen und
mit dem Hammer auf irgendwas drauf
haauen ja das ist natürlich äh das kommt
natürlich nicht gut an aber um das noch
mal auszuführen diese diese Ruhe die
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger ähm nach
der sich viele sehnen also um jetzt sie
haben vorhin von von einer Friseurin
gesprochen ja ich war neulich bei meiner
ja die übrigens nicht AFD wäht also
glaube ich jedenfalls und die ähm und da
saß ich und erzählte über Politik und
was sie was im bayerischen
Landtagswahlkampf gerade passiert und
ähm dann stand die Frau neben mir auf
die auf dem Stuhl neben mir saß und auch
gerade frisiert wurde und meinte sie
möchte ihre Ruhe haben es war natürlich
wahrscheinlich einfach auch eine
uninteressante Geschichte die ich da
erzählt habe aber ich merkte so die
Leute wollen irgendwie vielleicht mit
Politik gerade jedenfalls nicht beim
Friseur sie wollen irgendwie in Ruhe
gelassen werden und die Grünen jetzt bin
ich bei den Grünen die sind eben so die
quellgeister ja das sind diejenigen die
sie sagen übergriffig die Grünen selber
oder befürworte würden sagen na ja wir
müssen eben den
Modernisierungsschub Stau auflösen wir
müssen Vorschläge machen wir wollen uns
bewegen und vielleicht übertreiben sie
ja auch auf der an der ein oder anderen
Stelle oder sie überfordern das Land mit
mit ihrem Zug zum Ziel aber was ich
finde was man schon sagen kann ist dass
sie zumindest mal Vorschläge machen und
dass sie den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
nicht einfach nur versprechen ihr
braucht euch nicht ändern es kann alles
so bleiben wie es immer schon war früher
war alles besser Ciao servver sind zwei
Begriffe gefallen sie sagen ähm sie sind
quellgeister sie sagen die Grünen sein
übergriffig andere sagen seine
verbotspartei die wollte uns
vorschreiben was wir zu essen und sonst
ganzen Tag machen sollen zu essen äh und
und andere ähm also in den privaten
Lebensbereich eindringen ist das
tatsächlich so nehmen die Leute die
Grünen so war ist immer die Frage wer
die Leute sind ne und ich meine die
Grünen haben ja jetzt trotz Verlusten in
beiden landtagswahen trotzdem veritable
Ergebnisse eingefahren so in ein in
einem ganz langen Kext Verluste erlitten
genau sie haben sie haben
verloren an an Prozentpunkt sind aber
trotzdem jetzt sagen wir mal weit davon
entfernt wo jetzt wo jetzt auch andere
Parteien sozusagen sich sich bewegen von
den Niveaus her ich denke es gibt schon
einen einen Teil in der Bevölkerung der
sagt dieses was sie als übergriffig
bezeichnen
der sich daran stört der das sind mit
Sicherheit auch 50 60% die sagen das ist
mir alles viel zu direktiv viel zu in
ins ins Private rein äh regiert auf der
anderen Seite haben Sie natürlich eine
eine wirklich
loyale Kernklientel die sagt eigentlich
sind wir auf Kurs und ähm und und und
die Dinge werden entsprechend auch
umgesetzt und und und das ist auch das
ist auch gut so ich denke da gibt's es
nicht den einen Wähler und und die eine
Wählerin der da so der da steht es ist
halt eine unglaubliche Polarisierung
wenn man sozusagen die Grünen auf der
einen Seite hinlegt und dann die AFD z.B
auf der anderen Seite dann sind es dann
hat man das Gefühl dass diese dass diese
Bürger in komplett anderen Welten leben
die einen sagen eigentlich alles
wunderbar und die Transformation geht
voran wir müssen da mehr tun und die
anderen sagen um Gottes Willen wir haben
Angst vor allem möglichen ihr dreht an
allen Schrauben unser Wohlstand ist in
Gefahr und genau in dem in dem Kontext
bewegt sich natürlich jetzt auch die
ampelregierung und und die politische
Diskussion leider nur noch ganz kurz
Zeit jetzt ist gerade die Halbzeit für
die Ampel besser gesagt die zweite
Halbzeit hat gerade begonnen wir haben
festgestellt die gtinenpredigt des
Trainers in der ben hat offenbar nichts
genutzt äh wird sie noch durchhalten bis
zum Herbst 2025 die ist die
ist wie wie verdammt dazu durchzuhalten
Stellen s sich Wahlen jetzt vor aber es
wird ja nicht es wird ja nicht besser es
kommen ja jetzt noch Landtag es geht ja
aber darum dass sie es durchhalten das
werden sie tun der Kitte macht hält
normalerweise die drei Parteien
unweigerlich zusammen weil alle wissen
wir stürzen ab wenn wir jetzt Neuwahlen
haben aber mittlerweile muss ich Ihnen
sagen die Vorstellung es geht zwei Jahre
so weiter ist für viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ein Schreckbild und insofern
glaube ich und man kann es manchmal aus
manchen Äußerungen der Ampel Teilnehmer
auch schon rausen sind ja mittlerweile
fast Akte der Verzweiflung wenn
beispielsweise ein spdvorsitz muss man
sich bewusst machen den eigenen Kanzler
bzw die Koalition um Orientierung anflht
also wenn es nicht besser wird wird
irgendwann glaube ich der Druck so groß
werden dass ich mir vorstellen kann dass
es nicht zwei Jahre so weiter geht ja
vor allem hat ja die Union ihre
kanzlerkandidatenfrage immer noch nicht
geklärt was bei der letzten Wahl ja auch
nicht dazu geführt hat dass sie ein
finantes Ergebnis eingefahren haben also
wenn sie jetzt neueewahlen machen würden
und sie würden mit Friedrich merärz
antreten das wäre wahrscheinlich die
beste
Wahl natürlich mer eine coole Idee geh
hab gesagt schmeiß die Grünen raus Olaf
und dann nim nehmt er uns dann wäre Erek
wir uns nach der großen Koalition Sehnen
oder also ich habe auch schon überlegt
ob man in dem Leitartikel mal irgendwie
also man liest es ja auch so durch bei
den Kollegen das immer mal wieder dass
es irgendwie immer mal wieder heißt
vielleicht war schwarzrot doch nicht das
blödeste selbst Markus Söder hat jetzt
mal Richtung rot geblinkt und gesagt na
ja die Freien Wähler vielleicht dar ich
nur einen Begriff noch zu dem Einführen
Sie diese drei Parteien sind ja nicht
die einzigen die eine Krise durchmachen
die CDU macht auch die ich nenne das so
das sind die
verantwortungsparteien der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland des des der
Demokratie mit dem modernsten
Grundgesetz der Welt das sind die
verantwortungsparteien die vier und die
haben alle ein ganz großes
existenzielles Problem gut
bedanke mich für diese dreelstunde bei
aner Klaus Roland abbold Frank Meer
Albrecht von Lucke Liebe Zuschauerin und
Zuschauer das war durchaus unterhaltsam
morgen wird es nicht so unterhaltsam in
der phönixrunde das sagt schon der Titel
Angriff auf israel droht ein
Flächenbrand aktuelles bei Phönix der
Tag mit Julia Grimm darin das Neueste
aus dem Nahen Osten nach dem
Terrorangriff der Hamas auf Israel
bleiben Sie bei
[Musik]
uns